okay this is new for me
I hope I'm live I hope everything is
working okay I was just doing some
testing fixing some last-minute issues
but it's good to be here
it's Saturday its sub Saturday and I
think for the next what it's 2 p.m. for
the next 3 hours I'll be playing
subscribers it's my first time streaming
on the chest comm twitch channel so this
is exciting if people want to challenge
me I don't know if we have like a
challenge command in the chat or if
people have to do it manually my
username on chest comm is just IM rosen
pretty straightforward
I'm taking I'm taking subscriber
challenges but if there's a shortage of
subscribers if there's a shortage of
subscribers you better subscribe but if
not ok I'm getting one challenge I don't
know if he's a subscriber but I think he
deserves a game first first person
challenging me max what's his name max
blue neck good luck first game of the
day it's gonna be a lot of chess let's
play let's play something something
exotic let's play something normal I'll
just play like symmetrical see what he's
up to
might have a London system Bishop at 4
92 92 is a weird move order might be
signifying that he wants to play like a
collie let's play c5 whoa there's people
in the chat I was wondering why there is
no one in the chat I had my like
personal twitch chat open not the chest
icon chat now I have it open ok so he's
definitely going for Kali I'm gonna take
on
d4 and then play knight c6 and this is
just a simple way of playing we have we
have what's known as the Carlsbad
structure where blacks missing a C pawn
White's missing an e pawn so it's
already a little bit unbalanced and I'm
just gonna go for like very normal
development White's playing very quickly
wants to grab this pawn and be sudden I
could defend I mean Queen c7 looks
normal wait I have to be careful Queen
c7 Oh Queen c7 there's no Bishop f4 cuz
that would be illegal
yeah let's play Queen c7 yeah hello two
people in the chats Oh max
M'Lynn neck is in the chat and he's a
mod and he's a subscriber eight months
subscriber and a five kage here nice so
I'm playing someone very deserving of a
game but I'm not going to show any mercy
creating the battery I'm not actually
sure which way I want to castle I'm kind
of flexible here let's move back with
the bishop let's for some tea to for
three hours of chess I pulled out my big
teapot like filled to the brim not sure
if I'll make it through all of this one
cup at a time
c4 c4 White's wanting an IQ P but trying
to gain initiative and I could take nine
a five doesn't seem to do much because
Queen b5 work with a four check I could
also just leave the tension and castle
like castling if white plays he 5 I
played Bishop f4 let's do that I didn't
want to take and allow the knight to
come in and hit the bishop
what T am i drinking this afternoon
green tea I think it has some fancy name
though it's like super matcha green tea
okay let's play Bishop f4 it looks like
a weird square for the bishop but it's
supported by the queen bishops are kind
of working together controlling a lot of
squares and White's territory this pawn
is a potential weakness and whites a
little bit overextended I mean at some
point I might want to play this move
also 94 ideas I should move quicker
though I forgot this is what's chess
chess bay 19 months thanks for subbing
and we have this sub notification thing
which is working and I'm getting the
bishop pair Knight takes D 3 is coming
then maybe Bishop g6 Mel start harassing
the Queen Bishop g6 is it necessary
let's play Bishop g6 bishops doing work
this LightSquared bishop is especially
powerful because white doesn't have a
great way of controlling the light
squares I have this move but I probably
don't want to trade let's play rook rook
F c8 let's play rook F c8 I want to play
b6 and get rid of the pawn now I play 94
hitting the Queen I don't actually want
to trade bishops but I might have to
there is no hiding place for the bishop
on f4 I might leave the bishop Maya for
allow the Queen to take so I am getting
more challenges if you're a sub you can
challenge me and I'll likely accept
it'll be three hours of playing viewers
subscribers etc let's play b6 wait b6
weird stuff can happen takes takes takes
I might be losing a pawn but I'll be
getting open files I'm not going for
that line well now I might be winning
upon ticks
so there's no increment so I do have to
be time conscious yeah so I could take
we're gonna trade off some stuff I'm
looking for eventual ideas maybe this
move can win be two half gamer man with
a sub thanks half gamer man five months
I mean this is very pleasant I mean
these pieces they're working together
whites pieces are kind of just sitting
sitting on the couch doing nothing could
take on b2 now and white can't contest
the B file because I'm controlling be
one with the bishop it takes on a seven
it's still equal material I can play
Bishop b4 maybe just centralize I want
to take on f3 now if the knight moves to
d4 I could take on g2 and then take on
d4 I do have to be careful though for
like back rank mates I can't allow
lights to moves in a row sitting on the
couch doing nothing that's not a
personal attack unless you take it
personally so now this is a personal
attack though because my rook is very
dear to me and I can't take the pawn
because meet Queen B 8 maybe Queen B it
seems passive but Queen B eights I don't
know it defends so I'm actually
threatening to take and I'm still
threatening to take here so I have
multiple threats c6 so now I can take a
pawn
and the game's gonna revolve around the
c6 pawn I want to win it but maybe I
should make loose for the King g6 or
let's play h6
when you're scared of getting back rank
may that it's important to make lift and
now now I'll be free to play moves like
I'm Brooke c7 maybe I could could've
played rook c7 last move into Queen c7
at Queen c7 White has to trade Queens
and then I'll have two threats assuming
Queen takes c7 rook takes c7 I'll be
threatening this as well as rook b6
still down on time but I'm soon going to
be up in ponds so I could say they for
pawn yeah but now I'm gonna win the C
pawn and I'll have one happy pawn island
and white will have three very lonely
pawn islands rook is behind the passed
pawn let's play this move I'll bring the
King in I'll bring the King in as far as
I can let's do that it's still gonna
take work because my King might be out
of play can repeat once maybe e5 should
be included trying to take the pawn
expecting rook a 1 ooh let's do this
move now e5 restrict the King create a
barrier and now move back
I might repeat again actually mmm do
this and now let's take I'm holding on
to everything
ah that's an annoying move let's take
and rook f6 I want to win that pawn my
Kings kind of caught
so let's attack the brook I'll move the
King move the King some more ok now I'm
happy still down on time I gotta play
faster
let's check the King you can start
pretty moving take the pawn opposition
check let's play King of 6 ok always
play off 6 and always pre move when
you're throwing time well I can multi
pre move I forgot about that check
always pre-move spy checks to slow the
ponent down and push past pawns and
maybe checkmate
oh it's close to mating they're good
game
I was actually close came down to the
end some time scramble I mean I think
black was always in control and the
position was always evolving like in
favor of black but I have to move faster
it's hard to talk and play and drink tea
and read the chat at the same time shout
out to everyone in the chat Joe Bruns
talk ffice spicy cat litter may be
related to spicy caterpillar alright so
um how does this work
this is still very new for me even if I
have one game of experience I know
there's something about a queue so do I
just occur in queue wind and make hell
tall so let me find my challenges oh so
I'm gonna play wind first
[Music]
how I accept click the name chat I try
and follow I don't see where to accept
unless I have to make the board bigger
ones moment here I think the board is
too are the windows too small so it's
not showing the except on unless I just
click it no oh there we go ok let me put
that back where it came from
yeah I think for the queue people I'll
have to challenge me because I'm able to
accept when the challenge like pops up
in the corner ok let's play e5 we're
gonna have a King's pawn what this is
rating below 1600 let's play something
something which looks boring like a
petrikov but we'll try and make it
exciting
mmm ok let's play Bishop c5 this could
be a very sharp line there's like one
good move for a white in this position
which stronger players will know if my
opponent doesn't know then he's probably
like in trouble yeah Bishop e3 not the
move to play we'll go over this
afterwards because this is a probably an
important lesson okay so now White's
pawn structure is a bit damaged
I can play d5 let's play d5
see for it's weird the center is opening
up but we're both on your developed
let's try this move
I just want to develop as quickly as
possible control the center castle and
then try and exploit these weak pawns
let's play Bishop takes so I do have
pending challenges good to see it looks
like there is a queue also good to see
Bishop d3 I think I'll start with with
this move I want to play Knight c5 just
attack the Bishop b4 prophylaxis
stopping Knight c5 it's a fascinating
move let's play a5 get rid of the pawn
drink some tea I don't think there's a
great way for a white to maintain the
pawn on b4 either has to do this or this
and Knight c5 will come queen a4 Wow
pinning the night
a good take
attacking the Queen and now I'll play
Knight c5 attacking the bishop the
initiative is beginning like there's so
many nice minor pieces in the center
they're working together everything is
nicely defended this bishops not
defended I want to do some some dirty
fork Knights I guess I have to take with
my knight here yeah let's take with the
Knights hey another sub a few more Suggs
blooper one and cold player in 1992
thanks for subbing yeah white actually
kind of is surviving I want a castle but
it's not legal these chests calm bugs
I could play c5 let's play c5 get rid of
the Queen if Queen b5 there's Bishop c6
I'll keep some initiative all right King
safety so I like the bishop
I like White's weak pawns bjh solving
the ultimate mod thanks for subbing 26
months that's like over 2 years it's a
long time man 2 years ago I was still
like a college student
a3 what is a3 I think my opponent just
wants to confuse me lots what do I do
here how do i improve I can push up on
play rook e8 let's play rookie Yates I
mean it's a half-open file these pawns
are going to be future victims probably
of the row
yeah and if might develops like we could
trade everything well Trey that Lisa
Knights and then just gonna play
positionally keep the pressure I'm
defending the sky so now I'm trying to
take the Knights remove the defender win
the pawn then the other pawn will be
weak just trying to be solid I'm a math
whiz oh because I I can count months and
convert them into years it took a lot of
schooling to make that happen
okay so there's a lot of pressure here I
mean I could take the night then rook
takes e5 looks reasonable capturing and
defending and planning the double up to
I think these pawns are still weak at
the higher levels all it takes is like
one pawn to win a game this game it
might be like a few pawns that will
eventually win so f7 is currently
attacked but it's also defended so let's
double up now white might also double up
and then I'll actually have to defend
rook f1 probably rookie seven maybe rook
87 and similar to last game I have to
watch out for the back rank and we have
another sub Nicola are we struggle with
this name I should learn how to
pronounce it's Nicola still sin how'd I
do
is it still sinners star Jason okay
we're gonna make looped for the King
again
this is very reminiscent of last game
like the first two games of this stream
it's all about just like making Lou for
the King not getting made in attacking
the pawns weak pawns karpova in school
of chess
yeah so people should listen to bjh in
the chats because he know he knows
what's going on more than me at least in
terms of logistics a for let's play good
play b6 I'm solid move mini pawn chain
play rookie six let's play rookie six
positions like this just be patient
King f2 now do I push good push
it's a passed pawn I open up the c5
square maybe for the Queen you're up d8
I could push some more not getting
needed wait
the Queen was attacked I forgot the
Queen was attacked I was so focused on
pushing a passed pawn well he see it
he's watching the stream I'll see it Wow
rook t7 well now I can't win the Queen I
mean I could trade it's gonna be a
winning endgame wait can I trade and
play rook c5 and then takes now King you
to the Kings too close I mean I think I
have to trade anyway rook be - that was
unnecessary yeah let's check I could
have been a lot easier
I pushed the pawn with multiple
intentions flavor of g6 I'll win this
pawn let's how do I meet the King I
could take this way white will win f7
the law when h2 and then I'll have some
mating net I better have some mating
that
I might have to include some pawns put
the pawns to work
yeah like g5 threatening me than one hmm
it's actually not a bad move let's play
okay let's let's do that and then trade
rooks scared of this White King down on
time too this is very similar to last
game where it's another time scramble in
a rook ending which I'm slightly down on
time but not by too much and now I'll
start pre moving and it's going to be
like three on zero on the Kings side
always play off six and this is where
pre moves come into play check check
could just pre move the rest of the game
whoa
opponents pre moving too though okay
this is going to be GG there we go okay
so a slow build up to a really quick
finale well there's many takeaways from
that game the biggest takeaway is
probably don't forget about free Queens
was this a moment to go far far back
when I played I played pawn c4 yeah pawn
c4 explosive I forgot it was kind of
opening up the lane for my rook we both
forgot it's like some random blind spot
I was so excited because my Queen was
supporting the pawn I even saw the idea
of rook c5 to supports I didn't see her
takes b5 man
all right well oh there's one more one
more thing I wanted to just show in the
opening though and then then we'll move
on and I'll play more games because this
is one of the more like testing lines
against the petrov like white tries to
to create imbalances early and avoid any
symmetrical position and after it takes
takes Bishop c5 I first this looks very
good for black but if you know what
you're doing is white and you're
prepared you can play Bishop c4 and this
is a fascinating line now I would
recommend learning this with like the
like the opening database and the engine
because the lines got very complex I
think the main line is something like
Knight takes f2 Bishop takes f7 King
takes f7 Queen d5 check and then yeah
then the King has to go to g6 because if
the King moves okay if the King moves to
f8 you take the bishop with check and
then you pick up the Knights if the King
goes to e8 problem is Queen takes e5
Knight takes h1 Bishop g5 so I don't
know how prepared I would be to go into
this line I think also white probably
has a draw like with Perpetual somehow
like if you're a weaker player and
you're playing against a strong like GM
and they're playing the petrov this is
not a bad line to go into his whites
it's also like it takes a lot of
knowledge so like not get Maidan as
black with the king on g6 I think I have
a video on this line you type in my name
into YouTube you type in like Gary Gary
losses in the Petra you should be able
to find it but thankfully my opponent
didn't know any of that played Bishop e3
and then that was pleasant
so um interesting games to start with
let's move on let's play another game uh
what's the cue who's the next challenger
whoever's next in the queue if you want
to challenge me um
oh thanks bgh for sharing the link
current queue make hell tall so I see
the name I'm not seeing like the plus
button um let me make the window like
much larger ah there there's a tiding
okay this is not the best approach but
it's an approach nonetheless then we're
gonna resize the board back and back to
where people can see it there we go okay
I'll get better at that
let's play e5 again we'll play that
hopefully we won't go into that petrov
language I just showed
oh he's playing it okay I'm ready for
the challenge was rated 1790 do I have
to go into it I think I have to go into
it I don't think I can like Bishop takes
F to King F 1 and then blacks actually
in trouble alright well this is why you
should not give away your secrets to the
whole world I'll come back to ablate you
oh wait there's no Queen e4 check as my
night controls e4 so maybe there's no
perpetual at least but my king is on g6
but okay if I don't get me that maybe
I'll be up material
this is great my phone's going into the
same line I just showed a king g6 on mu7
like bond cloud style not a bad day to
play this I'm trying to remember the
Giri game because I showed this like I
did all this research mainly from the
white side and I remember like at some
point black plays h6 and hides and prays
for dear life Bishop g5 this is a new
move so I believe why it is supposed to
take but this is still looking like very
scary my bishops hanging my Queens
hanging my knights randomly on f2 my
kings on g6 I could play c6 maybe could
play Queen I fates we're now fate
defends a bishop
I mean Queen I fate what else to do
there's Bishop e7 I'm Bishop e7 also
possible so these are two main moves but
it's blitz so I don't have much time
Queen f8 9 H 14 takes g5 let's do this
I don't see anything immediate for
whites like these moves are impossible
because my night like defends from
behind and this move just loses a bishop
and activates my King and I'm still
attacking the rook white could legally
castle here but then I have discovered
checks meanwhile I might be threatening
this wow he wants to destroy me
h5 coming I mean can I just take and
then if h5 I take more free stuff I like
free stuff
Queenie for why there's some line ticks
Queen efore Queen a 5 H 5 I lose my
queen so takes Queen e4 King h5 g for
his mates so king f7 Queen d5 I run away
and I'm alive I think I'm alive just run
back to e8 let's see if I missed
anything have some small time a shortage
but me as my king is getting exercise
run up and run back before like mu 15
and I still want to play h6 and just
like hide in the corner
I forgot I have the chest TV chat open
to shout out to people in the chest TV
chat mainly wind and whisk mike h 5 free
pawn like everything in life is free
right that's how the saying goes free
pawn my king is getting more exercise
I'm above rock and a pawn weight and a
knight I'm up a rook upon a night and
another pawn wait what does this
position do I take it
Queenie for King h3 Queen h4 King g2
queen g4 o queen g4 isn't almost made
but the knight g3 what is this King g4
Queenie for King h3 Queen h4 King g2
Queen g4 93 9 h4 there might be
perpetual I go for this move just making
sure I don't think I'm getting mated
like my King has no legal moves
currently but whatever piece checks a
king allows some escape like if Queen
here here ok now I run back yeah now my
king is done with its work out ready to
trade Queens and I'm up just so much
material my my opponent employed the
strategy which is known as SAC
everything it might be mates except I
don't think it's gonna be mates
let's move the knight back to g3 maybe
to f2 supported by the bishop
now I just have to watch all about time
again my time management still needs to
be worked on good play d6 maybe I'm just
trying to get my my queen or my Bishop
into play ecigs draba you six maybe c6
just attempting to remove the Queen from
defending the pawn now maybe d5 d5 looks
nice this pawn still really annoying ah
the Knights also Knights hanging more
free stuff
okay now White's kings of targets and
white scheme didn't get any exercise
that's not in the best shape to run can
i castle no I can't castle I've moved my
team too many times so what's the
meeting idea like Queen h1 maybe it's
just a matter of taking more material
when the rook Wow see sacking more stuff
hoping its mate a free night wait no I
see you lateral Queen moves especially
after last game let's check and then
free nights I almost hung my queen there
that was very tricky move
alright now let's take so I'm up uh uh
rook it's so much to count I'm up at
rook two nights so I just lost a bishop
not getting me that you're right let's
take this thing I'll win this pawn maybe
I want to play rook f8 next so I'm up
two nights a rook and upon my keen can't
really move my king still has no legal
moose kids controlling all these squares
the bishop but this King is more
attackable I want to do this and then
this eventually work f8 mmm move in
it's a nice thing about having extra
nights
well that was mates I was so excited
about the fork winning more material
that wasn't meat I guess that was mates
nothing can move
Lisa keen can't move that was a weird
game I would be fascinated to see like
what the engine thinks if White had
anything that game but I didn't really
see anything and I have a feeling I have
a feeling that Bishop g5 was actually
the mistake even though it looks logical
I mean it's very greedy on my part
activate my team like this but just went
up and back yeah worked out
but definitely a game that will require
further analysis on which I don't really
wanna do now so I want to play more suds
so if you're in the queue
I guess be bjh let me know Oh John Davis
is in the queue current queue John Davis
okay
shoutout to John Davis who we've played
a few times before he actually beat me
once in Bullitt um go to my challenges
and now okay this will just take a
moment expand accept and then reduce and
then do some more there we go oh do I
play against John Davis
it's play E for I play them a bunch of
times as as black yeah and he always
plays like King's gambit let's play this
move just a little bit bigger okay that
looks nice let's be aggressive let's
play f4 g6 this is a big no-no I don't
know if I can punish it right away
though but it's usually weakening to
like the dark squares I'll play another
three here I'm gonna try and punish
black right away I'm gonna play d4 and
then if takes I'm gonna play Knight b5
because the square looks very juicy like
d6 is so weak d5 is what I like to see
inviting e5
now I'm gonna go in for a very quick
attack it's actually very hard for Locke
to control the square he might have to
play Bishop f8 and I'm temporarily down
upon but I can win it back whenever and
if he allows 96 I'll play 96 followed by
night at 7 woo her knight Knight g5
threatening at 7 + f7
I mean I could win a pawn but I could
also be forking this is like an opening
dream come true this is so much less
stressful compared to last game at this
point last game my King was on like h5
Knight f5 so I think I can just take f7
but if I take off 7 there's Queen here
this is a situation I want to like avoid
all messiness keep things clean I'll
take with this night expecting the Queen
to move to e7 okay I'll take the rook
now I won material oh it's probably time
to develop
I could play g4 let's develop though
maybe I'll set up like some trap like a
3 and Bishop b4
[Music]
oh let's focus in the center I'm not
gonna go 40 tactics just simple moves
Wow allow this it's gonna play d4 next
just have to slightly annoying but I
don't know this is like a benign tumor
like it looks annoying but it's not
really doing anything too harmful yet
I'll put the nylon e4 I'll work around
the pawns
at some point I'll play c3 I'll be very
happy until I drop the knight back to to
d6 ya 96 this is what we call an octopus
now the horse not a knight has eight
tentacles place III here like Bishop c4
place III okay so I see the current
queue so the next person will be blob
and then chest pots are Utah Jazz pots
are Utah yeah Utah I know has a growing
chest community already have a few
students from there and Jackie the Swede
with a sub now Jackie this week can be
added to the queue if you want uh b6 I
mean I could take the pawn maybe there's
no rush I'm not like fully Russian only
half Russian and now I'm attacking the
Knights I'm hoping for like some can
nevermind wanted to leap in the night
somehow maybe B for attacking the knight
again and then the night will be fee and
cathode but that's actually not a bad
like square because then I might have to
trade off my beautiful nights or my
beautiful octopus I don't want to take
and they'll give black a beautiful
bishop
oh let's take at least once yeah my
octopus is more beautiful than the
bishop and I'm gonna win the pawn and
being up the exchange is actually very
nice in this position especially when
there's one open file very simple plan
just doubling up I'm gonna try and keep
control I cook yeah look see - nothing
too special eventually I want to play
rook c7 invade maybe rook c7 eventually
Knight f7 now rook c7 Queen h4 attacks
the sky I could play g3 first hmm
let's play yeah let's play g3 first like
defend everything cover h4 and now like
rook c7 almost traps a queen like there
might actually be some potential Queen
chop like I'm threatening this move now
and then the Queen would actually be
trapped
I'm also threatening this to fork the
night in the rook so it is a question
like which piece is going to land on f7
also tog II 7 with a sub taki 7 are you
still in Iceland also how's the weather
in Iceland because I feel like the
weather in Chicago is colder than
Iceland right now another plan here is
just to double up on the seventh like
put both rooks in heaven I cook f7
[Music]
and black can't really fight for this
e-file you might just sack the Queen
here now let's play rook CC 7 yeah 7 7
this pawn can't be defended it's still a
question how I'm 8 but like blacks
almost parrot like completely paralyzed
I'm controlling CH I mean this is
probably the only plan a5 so I could
take I mean maybe I just take on a5 if
the rook takes I have rook c8 ah but
then I lose both rooks maybe I should
take on each 7 first have to be a little
bit careful I also have this move Queen
c3 play Queen c3 threatening the rook
and threatening rook c8 still
threatening this life is good expecting
this actually I don't know what to
expect I mean he might try something
really desperate I don't know if he can
even like create any chaos here
everything seems controlled if this word
bughouse this would be very bad for me
like a queen on g2 or knight on h3 and I
began mated yeah thankfully this is
chess ok let's play this move
so there's rookie - ro G - it's just one
check completely harmless
I think if Bishop c4 I can take the rook
yeah nice game John Davis no mercy
now that's an opening you don't want to
repeat the c6 g6 um even though that
would probably wasn't the main mistake
it just gave me some unnecessary
opportunities and this is a nice lesson
like how to play as white like exploit
the pawns weaknesses right away and as
black you need to like be very
conscientious of like the dangerous
signs because this is nothing to mess
around with I think the best move here
is this like d6 because any five isn't
as strong because black can probably
take but yeah normally like if you play
Sicilian you should stick with either u6
or g6 you should not combine the two so
if you start with E six you should be a
bit more consistent either go for
immediately d5 or sometimes players will
do a six b5 like there should be seven
like keep it a bit slower oh yeah I was
and that was fun for me thanks for the
game and we have another sub what is
this name eleven trove Vlad eleven you
can join the queue if you want to
challenge me so the next the next person
is hopefully this is a person is blob or
blob or blow be alright so let me try
this again I mean go to my challenges um
interesting so this is below this all
expand click and deflate hey okay it
worked out um let's play do I play
maybe at some point I'll take opening
recommendations but so far I'm having
fun with my openings one since raining
1970 let's play the same opening as last
time is he gonna play g6
hopefully he's learned from other
people's mistakes
d5 okay so staying consistent this is a
very common way to meet like the the
close Sicilian or the Grand pretty not
have three natural move just want to
develop there's a few lines here for
black nine of six this is playable
asking for e5 I probably don't want to
commit to you five so early
because then it's hard to break through
the center
I could play Bishop b5 Bishop e5 looks
reasonable just developing there's a few
ways for block to block if Knight here
here or Bishop here I might I might play
Queen e2 against everything else will
see knight c6 I could also take right
away maybe I'll take right away or Queen
e2 I'm so conflicted
it's like we need to right away there's
usually a rule that if you're pinning a
piece you shouldn't take it right away
because I can't move anyway and now I
have ideas of like taking and unleashing
the e-file and there's lots of tension
if flack takes I'll take back here and
I'll always have the option of like
taking and trying to damage the
structure black would like to play
Bishop d7 but that just runs into this
this move runs into this so Bishop e7
mm-hmm it's Castle
staying patients now I'll take my it was
no longer pins I didn't want to deal
with ninety-four stuff and I'll play d3
and we'll actually have a positional
game I have some solid structure black
has a bishop pair but not the most
impressive bishop pair and there's a
very kind of specific plan for white to
play Knight a for b3 Bishop a 3c4 and
just try and paralyze black rook v8
doesn't scare me I'll start with b3 oh I
should host myself let me host myself I
forgot to tweet too
I got so like enthralled with like
figuring things out yeah
guess that's the one rule of like twitch
if you're on another channel you should
host yourself you go to my chat I'm
gonna still execute this plan I mean
this looks very straightforward 984 I
want to play c4 I want to fix the pawn
on c5 and play Bishop a3 and eventually
eventually when a pawn let's see this
will be very easy to type host chess you
have to be careful not to autocorrect to
cheese okay beautiful
c4 trying to destroy my plan I mean can
I just take the pawn if I take this way
then he takes this wedding so maybe I
play e5 first b5 first 420 bond cloud
just subscribes happy birthday if you
want to play we can have a very
interesting blonde cloud battle let's
take
let's take on c4 first the problem is
like after it takes I can't take with
the Queen because Bishop a6 or can I
wait takes takes bishop bishop a6 queen
takes c6 Bishop takes f1 Queen takes d7
it's just a mess
I don't really want to get into a mess
so let's play Bishop d2 just simple like
developing with tempo
maybe someone linked Eric's own channel
ah moobot delivers yeah my channel just
I am Rosen I stream on Twitch as well my
own channel people can follow me if you
want
let's do I take I guess I should take
what else to do I'm sensing some deja vu
very much related to the John Davis game
or the square it's just one square but
it's like a dream come true square for
an octopus or rook rook d1 maybe Rick F
do you want let's play rook rook F D 1
ok this is a matter of move order I have
to move quicker to play rook F do you
want getting off this diagonal also like
tying down the bishop to defending the
Knights
this tension will remain or not take
with a pond
I'll niche the rook whoa
I dropped a pond again these lateral
Queen moves not easy to see let's play
Knight c3 I actually have some nice
common sation I am threatening this pawn
I've relatively good pieces I guess I
win the pawn back maybe I'll get seventh
heaven again at least with one rook
I've ideas of this in this 94
immediately 94 93 94 93 rook d4 what's
going on there guess there's only one
way to find out
93 attacking the rook and cutting off
defense rook t4 defending the knight and
the rook and aligning with the Queen and
threatening Knight f6 looks decent also
ideas of c4
this is gonna be a time scramble this is
my highest rated opponent so far - II
just wonder Knight of 6 I think check
and win the Queen this is why tactics
are so important for blitz to punish
your opponent's and also not blunder
into opponent tactics ok that ended
really abruptly like I said it was gonna
be a fight and then it ended like in two
moves all it takes is one blunder that
was fun yeah was this opening I like the
position c4 was actually a good move if
Locke didn't play c4 and let me play c4
it would have been very nice and then
yeah maybe this position like Bishop a6
right away like keep the tension
I guess this was so playable I
completely forgot about my my f-pawn if
I saw it maybe I would play something
different like maybe I'd go for a knight
g5 and go for the manoeuvre immediately
you want me to play the Grob because I
didn't play it yesterday
yeah maybe we're getting to the point
where I will take opening
recommendations so I guess because I
need to challenge myself
someone needs to beat me right okay
let's play someone else
what's this q HS pots are Utah okay
where's Utah more importantly where's
chests pots are Utah okay so expand
accept deflate all right good luck
chests pots are you Tom very mysterious
picture I mean I can't play the Grob is
black and I can't play Les Mis more as
black either I'll play I'll point I have
six I'll be flexible it's playing at
veresov let's play d5 I'll just play
what I normally play against the veresov
yeah this is a tricky opening now I'm
gonna play a move which it looks very
peculiar suspicious move c6 it's kind of
a pet line against this pet line now I
play e5
and now the idea is if takes and I trade
Queens and have Knight g4 if my f3 I
think I have the smooth weights I have
to remember Bishop g4 takes so g4 takes
takes 97 maybe I just take let's just
take this can't be bad if Knight takes
all developed with tempo develop even
more with tempo for those of you who are
new with new to chess and don't know
what developing with tempo means it's
essentially when you bring out a piece
you attack in the pawns piece and in
doing so you gain time so for example I
gain time White has to do something okay
defended and developed but now I'll keep
let try and keep being annoying attack
the bishop we might see the ship g1
looks ugly but and sometimes you got to
do what you got to do if you don't see
another like great move for whites
if King if King me - I'm very happy to
take the bishop
now I'll castle castling isn't
necessarily about King safety it's more
about getting the rook in to play rook
e1 or at e8 rookie EA toward e8 but the
Knights well defended should probably
develop the Queen side play this move I
think there is some weird threat of
Knight takes c6 I actually don't know if
I could have played that immediately cuz
they're in some 97 ideas but now it's
too late
my bishops defended I want to access e5
square probably Knight g5 and we have
another positional game
Queens are off the board arguably black
is slightly better cuz this this pawn is
uh a bit lonely will trade miners put
the rook on you units yeah the problem
of the e pawns just so long-term targets
can't be defended by another white pawn
so over time the goal is to at least
keep the pawn blockaded and maybe he's
long term like just double up rooks
when don't you Castle there's cases
where you don't castle in chess
sometimes when Queens I trade that early
then it's better to lead the King in the
center but it's also important to get
the rooks into play play this move my
bishop my bishop was kind of hibernating
for a while but eventually it'll come to
life
rook GE one okay let's make the bishop
lively not sure what it's doing on e6
but it's controlling some squares at
this point it's just a matter of being
solid I might just wait until like white
blunders I might just keep playing solid
improving moves see if flight gives me
any opportunities I'm dreaming of
getting the night to e3 Knight g4 is
some idea let's start with rook t8 only
open file on the board have ideas of
this and this
b3 continued I'm actually not sure if I
want to double up on the E or D file
because this is a clear target if I
double up on the D file and Knight a3 is
played we might just end up trading a
lot Bishop c4 Wow so I could trade
everything and then just damage white
structure even more let's do this
I'll take with the night expecting night
takes then I'll take on d1 with the rook
and then I'll take on c4 with a knight
with the bishop and it's still equal
material and now okay I can't take hear
it because takes and then I get back
cremated so time to make some loops now
I'm probably threatening to take I do
have to watch out for rook d7 but the
structure it's just so weak let's put
the rook on e5 preventing pawn to e5 and
then the goal is to play 97 to c5 and
then eventually f5 and White's goal is
to move the King here which is met
nicely with Knight c5 or prevented
nicely with Knight c5 now all it takes
is one pawn to win a game haven't won
upon yet but liking the prospects
mm-hmm yeah so I'm allowing the rook to
invade I grew up da King g7 but again
this is like a benign tumor like it's
looks annoying but it's not gonna do any
harm like rook e8 a 6b sevens always
defended by the knight and this line is
very hard to remove now I want to take
the pawn but I want to defend that pawn
as well so I should probably make some
other improvements could activate the
King I mean I could take the pawn let's
start with a six kind of a slow move but
I want to take twice on e4 and not have
my a 7-pound be attacked in the end okay
now take sticks takes rook c7 takes
takes rook a4 King b2 not sure if I want
to go down those lines I'm gonna play h5
I can win this pawn whatever I just want
to make like the most improvements
possible because it might come down to
some pawn race on the Kings side it
might also come down to just flagging my
opponent yeah now I think it's time to
take expecting RUP t7 ooh okay now I'm
just gonna munch on some pawns up to
pawns up time life is good
I have some more tea let's play b5
okay second cup of tea I've got one more
cup just over an hour into the stream we
could trade down show some King pong
technique yeah this is why pawns are so
valuable because you get to the end game
and the pawns eventually turn to Queens
at least if you have more of them than
your opponent's okay
nice game as the fights some weird
opening it was nice to use this like
that's preparation cuz I remember like
always being confused about this opening
like the veresov and I remember there
are times where I would be tricked into
like a French defense like if black
plays a six to early that e4 transposes
to French so yeah especially if I goes
for the scam bits this is like called
the black Mart Dean or gambit and this
applies to a lot of gambits least more
mainstream gambits where if you're
playing someone who's like really
excited to play gambit
sometimes it's better to just kill their
hopes and dreams and decline the gambit
and c6 is a nice way of just declining
and then after a five black got some
nice development and we didn't go into
this line but if takes takes and then
let's say King takes ready Knight g4 and
if Knight takes Rigby Knight takes e4 so
the lines work out nicely for black so
yeah if you're just joining I'm doing
what is called sub Saturdays first time
doing this first time streaming on the
chest comm channel you can challenge me
I know there's a queue
and I'm taking subscriber challenges
first the current queue is now in the
chat
Carl is his name Kars karna cero sounds
like beef or a steak
it's probably Spanish for something
let's play karna cero and then tal you
seven and Jack the Swede okay and I can
play a grub I guess I kind of committed
to it right okay let's expand accepts
deflate
oh I'm black again the grog will have to
wait well I'm playing a good player
let's play let's play a Sicilian I even
play the Sicilian yet I play low while
the Petrov's
I'll play time on of one of my main
lines Oh from Sweden
interesting Bishop e5 so this is
actually an interesting line there's
some traffic takes takes 92 Queen g5
with this line I think a6 is a move and
there's some theory like Bishop d3 this
is a very strange variation I'm going to
move back to c6 because I don't want to
allow the this damaged pawn structure
rook e1 find them let's play complete b5
to be careful of e5 ideas let's play b5
game space
I'm a little bit behind developments but
because the center is closed it's not so
uncomfortable and Bishop f1 is a good
move
oh can I get away with this right away
here here probably not because h3 so
I'll play d6 trying to slow down the e5
move now I just want to develop and why
wants to open the center before I
complete development one could take and
Bishop e7 I guess or should I take
probably Bishop e7 I'm a little bit
unsettled because I've touched nothing
on my Kings side except the e pawn but
if I get three moves I'll be I'll
hopefully be more comfortable
let's play Knight of 6 and we actually
have like some Shiv n again or
Scheveningen like setup we played
somewhat of a non-traditional move order
but this is like one of the most common
Sicilian structures have a bit more
space on the queenside a3 is a good sign
very happy to see a 3d means I have some
time castle next then the Queen side
play f3 also nice sign it's always just
playing solidly the Queen side play
usually involves okay first of all
having the C file and then secondly
usually going for this idea I might
start with Queen c7 create some battery
and this is really a dream square for
the night I'll play 95 not scared of f4
because of Knight g4 and I'm ready top
in if I get into c4 I'll be attacking
things
I'll be having tactical ideas to like
night take Knight to c4 and night takes
a3 is one idea make use of the C file
battery do I have to play h5 in this
position h5 is not under my radar even
though sometimes it's played to stop g4
usually it should not be played when
you're castled it's more common when the
rook is on h8 I think I want to keep the
focus on the Queen side there's also
ideas of d5 and try and break down this
pawn chain maybe get the bishop to a
more active Square whoa sacrificing a
piece probably for three pawns
I should probably accept that wait is it
for three pawns Queen b8
there's Bishop a7 Queen a8 I think
that's okay it was gonna be very strange
but I'm happy to have an extra minor
piece here I know like three pawns is
technically equivalent to a minor piece
but modern pieces are usually just more
valuable in the middle game hey we have
our attacker and he approves it's always
what I've wanted in life approval from
our attacker so I have to play Queen a
it's only safe Queen move now it's a
question well why take here capturing
the 3rd pawn imagining takes takes takes
and then Knight c4 so Bishop d4 not
taking the pond so wide only has two
pawns and okay I could play Knight c4 go
play rook to e8 first a solid move
wait is it true
I played doubles and badminton with
Danny wrench I don't think I've ever
played badminton with Danny wrench
we've played ping pong though had some
very intense ping pong battles but this
was years ago
it's a long time ago as a very close
game - maybe Bishop measured a six
bishop was doing nothing staring at
White's pawn chain a four well this
might solid now could play knight c6
actually don't know it did you I'm just
gonna play like a neutral move putting
the ball back in White's courts okay
that's a scary move let's play this
controlling c7 yeah at this point it's
just playing like quick moves not
blundering maybe trying to provoke some
blunders from the opponents try and
tickle the c2 pond ideas of taking and
if Knight takes I can win c2
so there's queen Oh Queen see 6-7 would
be problematic maybe D 5 D 5 e 5 hmm
okay I don't want to get into a bad time
situation I'll start with Queen B 7 just
apply a little bit more pressure I'll
put the rook here probably getting ready
for d5 I should be 6 that's annoying
let's move back I might be losing this
pawn but maybe not because the Knights
tied down
ok d5 I'm inviting a 5 I'll probably put
the night on h7 and f8 and be safe
yeah just very safe White's gonna have
some space but I still have my extra
minor piece
I'll move the knight back it's a lot of
dancing around now the bishops tied down
to the pawn and I'm ready to take the
bishop and put the Bishop on c5 and win
more things that loses a pawn but I
don't know if I had anything better
still ready to take the bishop mm-hmm
winning my pawns back now I'm just up uh
a knight White has no pawns for it I
have two Center pawns there this is
looking very nice I'll be safe whoa if I
play that move there's a Knight takes c6
and he's frightening Bishop takes h6 to
have to be very careful do I do here
I might have to like give back up on
yeah I mean this will still keep me safe
I take c6 takes takes maybe you have
Bishop H for kind of an in-between trick
queen here Knight here this might be
working Queen g49 f6 I just want to
chase the Queen away from attacking this
Knight now I think I can oh I still
can't take there's a fork I'm very nifty
sway this
it's a skewer this bishops not defended
ha but it's gonna be a fork there's so
many random tactics happening all at
once thankfully I'm probably just gonna
win on time let's play this move is it a
trap that's not a trap Queen g4 I can
take the bishop and we'll trade and now
the icing on the cake Queen takes a
thwart rook takes up three and now
defend and flag alright interesting
finish now it's kind of a messy finish
like there's so much tension I think
white probably went wrong and by
sacrificing on b5 it's like one general
rule like you should value minor pieces
over pawns even like two or three pawns
but the opening was interesting like
this weird move order because I usually
play time on up and we got some position
which was an entirely time on of one
opening trot though which I mentioned
briefly but it's a trap which a lot of a
lot of people actually fall into where
it looks natural for white to take takes
maybe I can move the pieces take stakes
92 but then Queen g5 unbox better here
double attack
I think blacks just weighing upon but my
opponent didn't fall into that it was
the fights so I haven't lost a game I
thought I was gonna lose a lot of games
I prepared for the worst that's working
out but my energy levels slowly I'm
actually they're staying okay
as long as I keep drinking this this tea
is green tea has caffeine right let's
play uh let's play the next person on
the cute Auggie seven from Iceland I
asked the weather like how it is in
Iceland but I forget what the response
was oh let's make this bigger
where's talky-talky some smaller all
right ooh okay don't take this as an
insult but I'm playing the Grob because
people are telling me to play the Grob
it says hey I am Rosen I'm playing this
in dedication to you ie 5 I don't
usually play the Grob so what do I play
your Bishop g2 probably Bishop g2 makes
sense I guess the idea of the gras like
you put the bishop on the long diagonal
you gain space on the Kings side with
your Jeep on I think c4 is a common move
wait play the Grob says I stopped
playing the Grob a long time ago that's
so sad cuz you have to change your
username or maybe your user name is
telling other people to play the grub
which is still ok d-4d for we're both
kind of extending pawns let's play Queen
B 3 attacking this pawn we could trade
like takes it's not really a trade cuz
I'm thinking my rook in the end I might
have ideas with Queen g3 like defend
attack get ready to pawn storm I don't
mind this position looks fun so if
you're just joining I'm playing
subscribers we have a Q Jackie the Swede
is Vardi us and vamp Lauren are gonna be
next h6 is such a random of preventing
g5 not sure if that's the most ambitious
idea let's just take a pawn I'm so
perplexed about h6 now I'll take a
bishop now I'm threatening to win the
rook so I can defend Black has a smooth
so I'm up a pawn I can't play g5 so
let's play d3 trying to have some solid
structure ah so maybe this is why he
played h6 to prevent g5 in this position
but I can still play g5 my bishop
supports it would like to get the pin
I'm realizing that if we trade on g5
lock has rook b8 and rook takes b2 but I
can take a seven it could be a mess cuz
there's Bishop before check and we'll
see what happens
that takes takes I guess after rook V a
queen takes a seven
there's only okay nevermind I won't have
to worry about any of that there's a
peace Evan whoa what no what did I do
oh it's click click I thought was
clicking drag but it's also click click
I lost a queen I wanted to play queen g2
and fianchetto my queen in my territory
no precious Queen okay well now I'm down
a queen but I'm up on time now I have an
extra pawn to right right
I have to stay calm when you make a
mistake you have to stay calm accept the
consequences
I would like to blame other people that
I should have been more careful with my
mouse okay let's take a night okay this
is gonna be competitive because I I have
a time advantage I have a rating
advantage but my opponent has a queen
advantage have to play route p1 but I
have an open file advantage and I have
the pair of knights
yeah I was try and stay focused castling
it's a good move
I want to attack but I also want to keep
my King safe I'll probably castle back
yeah I mean one strategy here is just
like don't get mated and try and flag
the guy that's hard when he has a queen
I don't have a queen
maybe h3 the idea of King here here here
and then eventually here to fork oh
that's a good move
she just wants to make another Queen cuz
one queen isn't enough um King h2 me
rook could attack along the C file okay
I'm gonna start with this move I just
want to poke and prod
I lost my time advantage I forgot I have
to move quickly to nicéphore maybe so
nice outpost attacks and pawns
now if a3 I take with Knights let's
defend the pond okay my idea is rook G 1
2 G 3 and then rook a G 1 and somehow
mating I don't want to trade nights wait
let's take upon f6 like guess I play
Knight g6 now this is gonna come down to
a time scramble now I want the the file
or the half-open file you know it's not
a bad move it's slightly uncomfortable
too let's play I want to do this but I'm
scared of this and then my my F pawn
will be hanging so I'm defending that
fun of my nights hanging - I could play
this move okay now I'm just going
all-out for the attack
like Knight h6 and like hope I'm somehow
meeting 9 H 6 to f5 holding on to this
pawn there's 96 ideas as well my h6
followed by Knight g6 ideas how is he
losing to a 1218 i blundered my queen
because i kind of mouse slipped my mouse
got too excited uh let's do Knight f5 or
rookie math 5 wait is there any trick
play right
three no matter five looks nice I just
want to keep things complicated not give
away my nights yeah that's a good move
let's do this move I'm probably gonna
regret that I want to play rook to e3
next and they will probably have to
somehow come back to f5 I actually like
my chances now my Kings relatively safe
I'm up on time there's no increment
still down the Queen but yeah more time
passes by I might sir
my it's gonna be tricky especially for
lower rated players okay let's check
again mm any like crazy mates Chuck it's
Chuck again all these spy checks
I'll plague Ricky one and now I want to
play this check just keep checking until
flagging or mating check okay that was a
close call slightly unnecessary Queen
blunder but yeah I mean when you blunder
your queen hold on to your Knights
because they're still tricky a nice game
taki seven I I actually like I liked the
opening like the grog worked out it was
just this Queen g5 move like it had its
journey to G - it was just took a tragic
like
pitstop the d5 square and after a bishop
takes a seven black ship late night a c7
no reason for Queen takes e7 maybe he
was thinking like Queen before and take
the pawn but I was more valuable like
hold onto your Knights even when you're
up a queen okay
maintaining my clean score maybe not
with the cleanest of games so um next in
that queue is Jackie the Swede
let's go expand Jackie where are you
wait I don't see Jackie the Swede is
there may be a different chess comm name
than twitch name if Jackie the Swede
isn't here I'll play Avard
evolved s Oh Jackie the suite is here
Jackie okay let's play evolved s first
wait I don't see evolved us either io
people see this but these are the people
challenging Oh Jackie the suite okay
nice and now expand back beautiful let's
play let's not play the grab let's play
a London
d6 let's play up yurts there's a d7
let's go for scholars mates okay if
black isn't pre moving any everything
then maybe I won't come for scholars
mates d6
wait what oh I forgot it's click click
again I did not intend to play Queen f3
but somehow I clicks the queen earlier
and I click that 3 square thankfully
that was not a mouse slip just have to
be very careful of that ah so it
highlights the piece I see okay this is
actually a reasonable way of playing
like my opponent's trying to be super
solid but eventually there's gonna be
some holes like at some point I'll play
like d5 or a5 and yeah I want to avoid
the so called Lotus gambit one game was
enough I could play the delayed Grob
played the grab is still in the chats
probably summoning g4g for actually
makes some sense
let's not trade off any minor pieces
there's a very common rule in chess when
you have more space or have more Center
don't trade miners the block is more
cramped yeah this is actually a very
reasonable plan like g4 g5 kick away the
night then maybe h4 h5 and then
eventually g6 so next players in the
queue are a Vardhan evolved us vamp lord
eleven Steffes five and nikolas toge sin
if you want to join the queue you can
subscribe and challenge me and then
message bjh i think that's how it works
let's play g4 if i get in g5 the night
will have to go back where it came from
maybe I'll even play like b4 b5 kick
around this time as well Wow g6
reminds me of the john davis game like
the combination of g6 and g6 are very
weakening to that six square in this
case have six nights i have a threat and
threatening to take the night and fork
as well as trap the queen this is like
free material plus a fork plus a queen
trap that's unfortunately for black
let's take again tough game seven moves
i think this is a quickest game of the
stream black could have kept playing but
it's tough when you lose a knight and
then a queen
back-to-back okay well um slightly
interesting opening Queen f3 not
intended to games in a row I did not
intend to certain Queen move but this
move was very reasonable let's move on
varves s I mean go to my challenges I
don't think I see the name though oh
it's evolved s I still don't see the
name next person in the queue is vamp
Lord so I'm going to look for evolved s
involved
yeah I'm not seeing it so we'll play
that lord if evolved is still around
I'll still be happy to play and I'll
look for it oh maybe I have to scroll
down okay I'll look to maybe scroll down
and see but for the time being let's
play chess ah let's play a Budapest I
haven't played the Budapest yet today
this is one of my favorite openings it's
fun when White's
accepts it it's also fun when white
declines it it's just a fun opening all
around
so this is actually the way that Carlson
played against me like the very first
time I ever played Carlson it was a
Bullock game and he premiered Knight c3
so it was kind of an unintended move and
then I went on to win somehow but this
is already like very pleasant for black
like more development I'm kind of
wishing my bishop was on like c5 Ted
Bishop takes f2 tattoos
wait a minute
does Knight does my t4 work here this is
a point in the day where I'm feeling a
little bit adventurous like 94 I can't
resist I'm sacking my queen with idea
that after Bishop takes d8 Knight takes
c3 pawn takes c3 Bishop takes c3 I win
the Queen back I think after the dust
settles I'll be up a pawn because I'll
have won the b2 pond so I'm going crazy
for just a pawn there's a potential
problem that white might just save the
queen
like after Bishop takes d8 I won't
reveal too much information but Bishop
takes d8 Knight takes c3 the Queen could
move somewhere and I might not win the
Queen back but I'll still have like a
really interesting scenario or I'll have
discovered a tax and some compensation
okay let's see what happens ah 'var if
I'm getting your challenge very good
you'll be next
now this very bizarre position I don't
think I've ever had this before either
this has never really come to mind
so Queen c2 oh this is so fascinating I
could play Knight d4 hitting the Queen
if Queen takes takes takes Knight c2 I
win the rook in the end if the Queen
moves somewhere then I have Knights in
white space like night here Queen here
but what's the move do I have him move
there 94-94 in Knight takes f2 this is
too much fun I don't have a queen but I
have minor pieces and they're doing work
this Queens attacked I'm dreaming of
like some mating ideas maybe it's a
little hard to conceive of a mate's
everything has to work together but I
think I'm gonna win the Queen back like
where does the Queen move the Queen
moves here I take on a2 Queen moves here
I take on a to defending the bishop if
the Queen moves here I play Knight e4
followed by Knight takes f2 King do you
want it would be a fork the Queen can't
move here here or here or here Knights
are powerful or here here and then we
already looked at all of these squares
the Queen is effectively trapped I think
so queen d3 okay so 94 looks promising
but is there anything better was some
like weird mates
I could play maybe Knight a for King d1
Knight takes B to King c1 I take on d3
yes I would rather win F to Bishop
attacking and now the family fork or the
so-called fork Knights the subs can use
their fork emotes or if you're a sub to
my channel you can use a fork and I
emotes and now we'll take the clean with
check and then we'll take the bishop and
now I'm up a bishop and a pawn and I'm
up on time was opening success okay
let's move the bishop somewhere maybe
back with intention of moving forward
okay I'll take I'll play d5 it's a pawn
sack I just wanna accelerate development
you could throw in a check develop with
tempo hey life is looking pretty good
play C 6
it's so nice having the bishop pair in
like a wide-open position because it's
just they control so many squares have
mating ideas if white doesn't resign
there's gonna be some mating net
hopefully if it gets to be two or even
like the third ring
so rookie three King eight - let's start
with this I'll play Bishop d3 hitting c4
I'll take c4 okay now rook d7 is a
threat I don't have any immediate check
so let's just defend and be safe I need
this guy to get into play Thank You rook
e8 rook will come down probably to e2
let's do this and then do this okay now
that was a fascinating opening like what
is this opening nights
efore I have a feeling it's dubious but
White has to play accurately so 94 in
this position takes takes maybe the
Queen could move somewhere else Queen
and Queen b3 there still may be Queen b3
but then still 94 so unusual but there's
some variation where like Queens eggs
before you give back the Queen and then
get a position like this where my
Knights attacked I have no time to take
the bishop
and blacks actually going to be down the
piece so this was probably the better
way of playing but it requires
calculation all right where's AQ a var
var if I missed it earlier hopefully
he's still here evolve evolve is here
okay expand and then accepts a var of
good luck what to play what haven't I
played yet
let's fight in English show some love
for England let's play this English is
actually one of my secondary openings
it's a fun line to play
yeah the queue is almost empty what do I
do if the queue is completely empty -
just wait or do puzzle rush uh d6 let's
play ad for ya the drawback of d6 the
Bishop's not so happy Wow okay we're
gonna have some old Indian it was
actually a playable opening like black
might go for this the kingside
fianchetto I like this face advantage
feels good okay let's take
imagining scenarios where all have like
Knights f5 and then okay never mind cuz
black just played g6 now I'm imagining
Bishop g5 attack the knight or do I go
insane and just like go for the pot sir
attack let's go for the pot sir attack
there's a certain breed of chess player
when they see g6 and h4 is automatic
this is usually the case for me and
bullet and blitz it's a little bit
borderline this case I'm probably not
necessary but it's gonna be fun
problem is I wanted like sack and take
twice on h5 but then the knight would be
hanging in the end so I think I'll start
with this move preparing to play h5 be
six now for a black lab e6 like double
fianchetto what could go wrong
b6 knight c6 chops a queen c5
yeah c5 it looks nice for black at first
but it's very weakening to d6 and I
don't know how black defends cuz I'm
attacking twice and pawns can move
backwards and once I get the Knight to
d6 it turns into an octopus a very
powerful octopus
I've had a lot of octa put octopi today
always nice
such nice nights this night can be
reinforced by the other nights or I can
just go for a fork go for the fork night
yeah let's do that
I've Keaney seven i can play ninety five
nights doing work honestly if ki e seven
i probably take the rook first because
I'm expecting Bishop takes and then I'll
have the other fork maybe he won't allow
it maybe I'll take on b2 I takes a chain
sword of hope chess yeah I'm pretty sure
octopi is right like spelling writes its
Latin or Greek or something queen jigs
me two best move uh let's play want to
sack a queen for some reason so I can
queen like it's like eating at iPod it
looks fun but it's just terrible
let's play ninety five just want to keep
initiative and not lose anything I'll
probably lose my Knights but I'll have
maybe some counter-attacks against the
Queen I'm just gonna continue making
threats
maybe this Knight can also become an
octopus this lights are gone or though I
don't think there's any hope in saving
it unless there's some miracle where's a
miracle knight of seven ideas or maybe
like these ideas to open h-file
yeah let's break they're bringing out
their knights there's possibility I'll
have both nights just in the corner just
chillin there's actually ideas here of
like Queen g6 King g8 Queen e6 King
takes and then still looking for the
mate ah here's wait a minute that
doesn't work I wanted to play this in
the night f7 but I would lose a rook to
play forcing moves let's play e5
there's a trick here if if Knight takes
e5 I have Queen d8 and that's just made
into and if that ooh that's attacking my
knight but the sites still hanging
it's like queen g2 first we might end up
trading Knights yeah this night has been
trapped for such a long time and it's
still trapped I go play Bishop h6 maybe
life is still pretty good Queen e5 let's
play Bishop e2 yeah now my knight can't
be taken the bishop is pinned Oh what's
what's an octopus in chess and octopuses
on Knights on e6 or g6 if you're white
it has eight tentacles it's so powerful
I explained it earlier apologies for the
people who had no idea what I'm talking
about
um do I take the bishop do I play off
three I play Bishop f4 complete Bishop
f4 maybe oh there's some funny chop
though let's play up three I'm trying to
induce Queen g3 King f1 Bishop move
somewhere and then I'll have Bishop f4
trapping the Queen okay none of that
happened so now I'll take the bishop can
I still legally Castle kingside pretty
sure I can
which should I take the bishop rook
every key AIDS
it'll be okay hmm okay so I was
considering castling to escape the
danger but that walks into maiden one
and my Queens attacked - so counseling
would be bad on multiple levels and
Queen G 3 is actually coming - I'm
actually in a little bit of trouble like
it's not comfortable
I mean I'll probably be okay I think I'd
better be okay now I might have to go
for some dirty flag
hey blacks getting a lot of counterplay
thankfully there's no Rick - yet cuz
kameen takes d8 and now my king will get
some exercise I think it's okay I think
there is a line there where I could have
actually been in trouble okay this is
definitely not trouble double attack and
flagging draw I was too slow to accept
the draw but good game he put up a fight
in this position I got so I probably
just got overconfident my Knights were
like falling and my king my king was
loose I probably should not have played
that three should probably just like
play Bishop III and be safe what was it
here where was a moment I think maybe in
this moment okay white had no time or
black had no time but Queen c3 perhaps a
bit stronger I guess I would have Queen
d2 there's still some weird lying like
Queen g3 King d1
I run away and it's probably okay for me
okay good game that's one way like how
low-rated players like okay there's a
1500 point difference between us
but like it was almost close to winning
okay one slip like castling it what it
didn't game over where when you get like
a bad position you just fight on you try
and create a counter play and even for
me like I'll sometimes get carried away
with my ideas and forget about the
opponent's ideas so we have a queue I'm
gonna be playing Steffes five step is
five let's find the challenge step is
five I don't see step as five I wonder
if there's like some maximum number of
challenges who is the next person in the
queue step is five if you're here and
you want to challenge me again feel free
then we have bundle Minh Oh step us five
okay nice playing step is five good luck
let's play have I not played on London
yet today let's play a London London is
like my true opening love in symmetrical
London you you play it's better to play
a bit differently with c4 idea to play
Queen b3 and attack the undefended pawn
and now black has to make some decision
[Music]
I mean he could play b6 he could play
like queen C aids we'll see what happens
knight c6 Knight c6 is actually the best
move here um and it actually has a nice
idea if takes this black could take
either away or take on d4 or play Knight
b4 um let's play to my play let's play
this move defend the pawn
I honestly might be getting into trouble
if black plays correctly here but we'll
see I don't think I want to say anything
my opponent might be watching some IP
I'm trying to figure out what I'm
referring to but I don't think it'll be
that bad for me okay nature is calling
so I'm gonna be right back my opponent
will have time to think hopefully by the
time I get back he'll still be thinking
if he moves and I'll be giving some time
odds but that's okay be right back
[Music]
okay ty mods have been given he played a
normal move Knight f6 I was scared of
this move ah let's develop let's play
Knight here I was really scared that
Bishop takes B 1 followed by this should
be for check but now things should be ok
if night before now I have I've rook c1
just defending everything to reload on
some more tea this is gonna be my final
cup I think unless I Wow 2 hours have
gone by so one more hour left
yeah my hands have been washed and clean
ready to not make any more mouths 6
compared to that few dirty games from
previously I think I've only made two
mouths lips so far I like those
back-to-back games with the Queen move
with the click click
she really finds out how to disable that
but now my opponents may be also washing
his hands leveling out the time like
it's only move 6 we've both spent more
than like half our time a 6 D move it's
actually tricky if I take what's idea if
I take there's still night here I don't
want to mess with that let's play this
move
just developing its the slowest opening
ever okay
I'm gonna speed things up if Bishop
takes q3 I'll take back with H pawn open
the H file let's play Bishop e2 hmm it
could play c5 maybe well let's just
castle be solid what opening was this
this was a London but it was like a
copycat variation so I went for an early
c4 in Queen b3 sort of like a London
Queens gambit hybrid and the knight is
arguably misplaced on c6 coming up on
looks like I can win a pawn here I'll
take twice on d5 or three times on d5
wait you're headed to Denver for a
tournament
is it the same tournament that like a
bunch of famous people are going to
because I heard Dani wrench is going
there and a bunch of other like strong
players hey another sub acid commander
25 if you want to play me send me a
challenge we have a queue of subscriber
challenges I think you can join the
queue by challenging me and messaging
bjh okay so we're gonna trade on d5 I'll
be up upon my queen is not entirely
trapped I'll swing over to h5 might do
some kind of impromptu King side attack
like g4g 5 mm no let's do it if Bishop
g4 I could play Queen h1 just for the
heck of it it's actually not a bad move
keep the Queen on h-file
maybe someday have scope along this
diagonal in the meantime I want to play
Knight g5 okay I'm fine Queen h1 the
king and the Queen are together that's
the goal of chess right
wait King h2 no that's a mouse lip
thankfully it's not like the worst mouse
left let's move back and let's take and
once yeah maybe my queen doesn't belong
on each one let's play King g2 I'll play
this and then this just hugging my king
with my pieces wow that's a fancy move
I'd play Bishop efore well let's play
queen h5 I'm ready for the sack okay
that was a weird game a lot of things
about that game very slow opening maybe
we both took some breaks in that game
early on I won the pawn then I did some
stuff in the corner with my pieces then
black lost on time one thing about the
opening because it is an interesting way
of playing a lot of players will play
like b6 for Queen c8 which leads to a
kind of pleasant position for whites
this is definitely the most challenging
move I actually don't know the theory
about this position but like just at
first glance it seems like black and
take Europe takes and then Bishop b4 I
have to give up castling rights like I
would probably have to bond cloud with
King e2 or King d1 like unintentional
bond cloud but yeah after after one move
Knight f6 and I felt very safe
so let's move on shout out to Shaun simp
in the chat we met we met in real life I
forgot like people in the chat exist in
real life too that's nice to see let me
know like in the chat if you if you know
me in real life always curious I thought
I had the chest TV chat open as well not
as active as a twitch chat but shout out
to Jaron and Soren chess and shout out
to everyone else too let's play some
more chests what's the Q current cube
mincho rusev is the only person can
acutest have one person where is Min Cho
min Cho ooh high rated relative to the
other opponents okay I'm black let's
play I'll play a Budapest if allowed
yeah let's have a Budapest
we've had one Budapest already but it
was declined now it's accepted play
Knight g4 and the point of this opening
I mean I give away a pawn temporarily
the goal is accelerate developments and
eventually when it back White has to
play e3 here and now I'll play knight c6
d 5 point can't be saved
Queen d5 is an attempt but it runs into
Queen c7 bjh asking if I'm going to PCL
finals I will be I'll be in San
Francisco I have to figure out how I'm
getting there I'm not sure if I'm flying
or taking a bus from San Francisco or a
bus from LA but I'll definitely be there
and 100 bits from are we supposed to
things are we supposed to joining the
bit leaderboard let's take a pawn with a
knight
I think I'll be doing like some
photography at the PCL finals so I
actually like I took photos there last
year and the photos I took last year are
are like everywhere now being used to
promote this year's event so I'm looking
forward to it was probably one of my
most like the most interesting and most
entertaining chess event I've ever been
to okay so we have some position let's
take on f3 and then I'll put the other
night on e5 and there's a really
interesting idea coming up start with
with rookie Yates normal move Black's
main idea in this position is Brooke a 6
and h6 just a reckless yeah a 94 is
playable played Bishop f8 I still want
to rough lift yeah let's do it
this is why I delay playing d6 and now
I'll play this guy's I get my lifting in
today even if it's not at the gym now I
have some attack Queen h4 and then like
later I'll play d6 and if white ever
plays h3 I'll have ideas of Bishop takes
h3 and life will be fun if or is kind of
annoying because now the rooks kind of
hits if I play this though then there's
9 of 5 if I play this could also play
this play rook g6 first do you even real
IFFT bro or is it brah or is it brah
I was debating this on a previous stream
if like what's the difference between a
bro and a bra and a bra or is there a
difference let's play could play this
move Queen h4 I just want to be
aggressive I'm still delaying d6 I don't
know if my bishop should like come out
of hibernation or maybe this bishop
should come out of hibernation more
quickly but now I have I have plans in
life if Knight f5 may be Queen h3
threatening mate I mean there's so much
potential like all my pieces have
attacking potential I mean this looks
for very fun oh but then Knight a5 wait
rook age six minus five I can just take
on h5 pretty sure that works and now
this bishop is basically pinned whoa I'm
a the green house that I make it green
ah if you hold down shift shift
right-click makes it green and you know
that I make it that I can make it blue -
this is so fascinating let's play Bishop
c5 on Bishop c5 is so close to me well
this Bishop is still going to be pinned
oh it's so close Bishop c5 King h1 it's
so so close I don't want to move my
Knights but I might have to
okay let's put the Bishop on c5 first
and then I'll decide I might end up
playing g6
might also end up just playing d6
I guess Bishop d4 for whites but Bishop
c4 I can take and then like Knight g4 I
really want to take here and then
somehow meet but it's not quick enough I
don't think so I take and play g6 how do
I can sack back the Queen so I could
play this move and it looks so bizarre
but let's do it the bishop still can't
move because then I just mail on each -
I'm threatening this also have ideas
we'll just bring my Bishop to control
the diagonal so queen g4 another bad
move and if I take I guess there's Queen
takes if I take on g4 first lose a
little bit of initiative I could play
like d5 but that doesn't quite work
either
hmm yeah maybe I don't have anything
here I mean I feel like I should have
something but I'll just do this we'll
trade and go into some queenless middle
game I'll still maybe have some attack
but I'm down about a minute on the clock
which is not that comfortable but I'll
try my best
White's thinking let's take the Queen
and then play 95 so very juicy square
ideas of having an octopus let's play my
Bishop g7 get the bishop to c6 you have
some time to make up always play off six
and maybe g6 - no let's just - I can't
take immediately mmm
what do I do here Bishop I have to move
much much quicker let's play this
expecting Knight e4 Knight f4 king f7
play c6 attack the Knights may be g5
coming attack the Knights some more oh
there's Bishop h5 but he didn't see it
now I have rook h8 ideas I've h-file
battery potential okay I'm down about 25
seconds
there's no increments
I'll have king e7 if needed let's defend
and trade defend some more f6 is sort of
tender I'll defend play g5 to defend -
or attack I can't do that yet attacking
efore I'm losing a bishop no that was a
very valuable thing to lose oh no I
might lose like the first game of today
oh this is so painful
I have to start pre moving stuff oh that
was a bad pre move ooh that was a bad
move - I'm losing a rook no binding upon
maybe I just have to like pray people
have to pray for me know I lost a game a
game I tried so hard got so far but in
the end what kind of matters there goes
my perfect streak 2 hours and 23 minutes
in GG min show rusev from what is this
flag from Bulgaria I've never been like
to Bulgaria I flew through like Varna I
was there for like 15 minutes of the
airports but yeah
played well like defuse my attack I was
so excited was this position I brought
my rook in I did even rook lift bro and
then I thought there should be like some
mating ideas but maybe I can I click
analyze
maybe clicking analyze will throw
everything off it brings up let's see ah
it throws stuff off to analyze like with
my brain or with my mouse I really
wanted to do this and then like g6 but
it just doesn't work now it has G for
Bishop T for
another idea is d6 and then takes this
also like I just don't have enough fuel
yeah I was too slow in the end - oh so
he's in the chat Sunoco you missed
Bishop takes g7 at one point maybe later
or was it that was much later I don't
think I can go forward because I I've
made some sub variation what was wrong
with Knight g4 Knight g4 Queen takes g4
so move I really want to play g4 is
under control
yeah I I discovered the the color the
colorful stuff at the wrong time
like all these colors can you make is
there yellow
no maybe there's no yellow it's blue
green and red
okay next in the queue is kind of pink
Jake this is a regular person in the
chat let's find him kind of pink Jake to
expand I'm gonna have to try and regain
my my dominance what to play let's play
this weird opening c5 yeah you three
he's a little bit timid let's play f5
what we call the Benoni touch now if I
was more commonly played maybe it's POC
- II played combined with c5 but it's
what I was going to play if I could play
d5 I'm still inviting d5 and this is
actually like a a playable way of
playing
I'll castle leaving the tension between
the pawns is there no one in the queue
do we have an empty queue we need a
subscriber who can jump in just jump in
camel clutch sure in the chat and are we
supposed to wait I didn't read the bit
message I didn't see the bit message it
was something about a hundred bits I
think it popped up but then it went away
I think yes you'll have to cheer more if
to send another bit message let's play
Knight a six
the idea is Knight c7 a six and B five
now this is a reasonable move
I play f4 no I can't play off for yet I
can play this move trying to unleash the
rook trying to stir up some sort of
attack of some sort it's a very unusual
structure because White has like very
solid center reasonable peace harmony
but black has some sort of weird harmony
to like now my bishops this Knight has
maybe a future from a six your Sun King
side attacking potential Knight takes f2
Zamu might x f2 might just be like
devastating for a white knight takes f2
King takes f2 and Bishop takes you to
check because of the rook I would win
the Queen let's do it if the Queen moves
I'll have something like Bishop d4 all
this looks so delicious
yeah I have a feeling like after 94 like
white had to be very careful of the rook
and Knight coordinating Queen d2 okay
that's that's what I like to see because
now the King like has no I think can't
really run and it can't hide my Queen d2
block the bishop white would would have
liked to play like Queen e2 in Bishop
III but now the king is aligned with my
rook which means there could be some
interesting ideas there's lots of ideas
but I guess it's a matter of executing
Knight h3 Bishop d3 it was even like
some quiet Bishop g4 was 93 would be
funny
93 pawn takes d3 Bishop takes d3 mates
all right let's play Knight e3 that's
just a funny move if white takes with
anything on d3 I play Bishop takes d3
mates
cuz it's double check and the King would
have no escape Wow wasn't nice finish it
was very nice finish double check means
yeah like white would like to block the
rook or take the bishop but you can't do
both at once kind of pink Jake in the
chat suffering that was a fun that's
some fun opening yeah I mean I think the
positions like very reasonable for
whites even after E for like in this
position I think taking is a mistake so
it just allows things to open up in my
favor
better move Prez probably something like
h3 just kick away the Knights much safer
remove to there's some idea like h3 if
the knight moves like here here like
could play maybe e5 if I move the Knight
to e5
then there's potential to take if Bishop
takes sinking f4 maybe and eventually
five oh yeah Knight h4 was uh is not the
safest approach current q is Simon wait
chess calm Simon let's play chess calm
Simon let's go here Simon
MTL okay Simon Says actually what does
Simon say guess we'll find out efore
let's play I'm actually gonna try and
play like ultra aggressively and when
the game as quickly as possible
whoa when white wants to do the same
thing so let's do the fall Kabir counter
gambits there's a fun line against Kings
gambit players instead of accepting the
pawn sacrifice I sacrifice a pawn of my
own and now I have a pawn on e4 it's
trying to restrict White's developments
defend the pawn and whites up upon but
there's a few things which make this
like very reasonable for black the one
big thing is this diagonal the King
can't easily castle and I'll be able to
develop like very normally Wow might
even consider playing c6 trade and get
the knight to c6 checking kid with a
tier 1 sub thanks checking kid if you
want
play join the queue challenge me I'm
taking five minute games it's almost
over
it's 4:33 Wow now we have a lot of up
time am I feeling French do I own
pissant I do I move the bishop I really
like my pawn but I don't like it that
much I am very happy actually to open
the e-file get the rook to Yates before
white can castle this Queen this may be
a potential target on d3 dreaming of
night before ideas I'll start with Ricky
aids hitting the king Wow woo okay
there's a nice move here I'm just gonna
play it and enjoy life because Knight f2
is basically just unstoppable cuz it's a
triple four and white can only remove
like one piece at a time
so I'm guaranteed at least some fork
yeah that's probably the best move now
I'm not even sure if I want to like play
Knight f2 and win material it seems like
there's more fun approaches because I'm
valuing my knight more than the rook I'm
gonna play 96
probably not objectively the best move
but I mean I'm just hoping to like have
this move of course he kills my hopes
and dreams complete g6 prepare Bishop f5
or I could play a very sneaky move he'll
play a sneaky move yeah the thing about
this position this is my sneaky move
we'll see if he sees the threat
the thing is white still has a hard time
defending against this the queen has
very few squares if the Queen moves to
d2 i play my e3 and every other square
is like controlled d2 is only safe Queen
move am I gonna trap the Queen Bishop d2
Knight c5 my Knights coming to life
we're okay the Queen has one safe move
d4 and then that's a question how to win
the Queen with some funny line Queen d4
Knight e4 Queens III then 9f2 I get the
fork there's also like Queen d4 Knight
b3 double attack the Queen when this
rook but I think I'm gonna win the Queen
I'm playing ID for Queen has to move
back and then they'll f2
okay that's probably the best approach
yet realizing the the doom and getting
the most valuable value for the Queen
and actually if we look based on just
pure point value it's still equal like
it's Brooke
Knight and pawn for Queen
the problem is White's King is still a
target in the center maybe some some
simple move h6 whoa Knight takes f7 okay
see what you got
d6 yeah I think I think white very
quickly runs out of fuel like a few
scary Chuck's or one scary check and now
the tables will hopefully turn I want to
play 93 but I should probably take back
the pawn now I'm threatening 93 with a
quadruple no the quintuple fork that
would be a five-way fork but now I can't
do it because the bishops not pinned
maybe I play rook c8 I'll line with the
King x-ray vision
play Bishop d6 defend the check unleash
the rook attack both bishops still ideas
of 93
is that the correct term quintuple fork
this double triple quadruple quintuple I
mean that's a lot of things like
attacked this this this ooh okay I want
to take there's so many pins in this
position like this is pinned to the king
and to the Queen that's actually a good
move let's take a bishop
counter-attacking attacking the pawn and
attacking I was attacking my other pawn
but now it's mainly this pawn still
threatening the fork downgraded to a
only a triple fork now it's only a
double fork still hitting stuff I might
just go for like some mating ideas or
some flagging ideas 35 seconds left
mmm I'm having to play a very sneaky
move I'm threatening maiden three with
this this and then this
what's gonna happen flagging mating or
resignation guess we'll find out
well this isn't immediately meaning but
it's very close let's let's take with
Bishop give the King no breathing room
mating alright big game Simon uh any
lessons to be learned
yeah don't mess with that counter gambit
except you kind of have to mess with it
the best approach is to go into that
line if we go back if your plate if you
play the Kings gambit this is one line
like a lot of players maybe aren't
comfortable playing against because it's
white you want to you want the attack
you want the initiative and black turns
the tables very early so taking the best
move and then can I recommend Bishop c4
yeah I think I better approaches to play
this move d3 like try and get rid of the
pawn as quickly as possible after Bishop
b4 Bishop d2 hey there's people in the
queue the checking kid and the bundle
man do I play bondwoman already I don't
think I played checking kid that's a
very recent subscriber also yeah play
faster next time too
especially when it splits okay let's
move on bond the checking kid checking
kid all right mm-hmm
hi reading from France I don't know how
to speak French oh I would have played
the French though too late I'm gonna
play in this line
I've only lost one game hopefully I'll
keep it that way
remember for Knights I actually enjoy
playing this as black or they'll play a
very questionable but tricky variation
Knight takes e4 it confuses a lot of
people the idea is that all the Knights
are attacking each other if white takes
a seemingly free nights I have queenie 7
and i have a win dot material and the
main point and this is great in blitz is
white is just confused in there there's
a lot of different options and it's not
easy to refute if you haven't seen it
before very good let's open it I think
it's playable like over the board too
because of refutation I can show it
after the game but refutation like even
if I plays perfectly it's only like plus
equals so this is one line we'll trade I
think this leads to just equal position
but I have a nice time advantage so I
can use a clock as a weapon John
Bartholomew strategy expecting takes
takes and then we can take some more
stuff it could get very weird actually
yeah night take e4 is the best move for
white at least in this position we can
go over this afterwards
what's the crown between the flag what
is this crown premium member nice
thought it could be some like sort of
royalty I don't have a crown I have a
flag I guess I might not a premium
member I thought I was okay so Knight
takes f7 I have to think like so many
things are hanging yeah I think I'm
supposed to take the knight I'm supposed
to take the knight in place c6 or wait
maybe d5 immediately all right now I
have to think King g6 yeah King g6 and
then C 65 I first learned this line it
was so random I was in st. Louis back it
was like maybe seven eight months ago I
was staying in the chess house house
near the Chess Club and in the house was
Grandmaster Maurice Janko or Miro Shenko
and he was like showing this just
randomly and it was so fascinating like
these lines
I remember him and talking about this
move but now what to do
c4 is interesting because I don't
necessarily want to play d5 I could play
Bishop c5 I'll start with Bishop c5
we'll see what white is up to and we
have another sub flailing ace thanks for
subbing with twitch crime feel free to
join the queue I'm supposed to end this
at 5 but
I mean maybe at some point we'll call
off the queue and make sure everyone who
joined gets a game or maybe I could
[Music]
simultaneous and then this that looks
fun
keeping the time advantage I'm trying to
stir up some initiative even though this
is already basically an end game we're
holding on move 14 both whites Kings a
target on d1 and he should get punished
for playing off three rights
can I take take Bishop c4 Bishop f5 King
b3 probably not necessary
I'll take with this pawn opening up the
file I have an IQ p but I have a C file
that's a good move actually now it's
actually really annoying let's play this
move
maybe transfer the rook I don't think
like can get away with this move unless
he wants to pull a fissure I'll play
this trying be solid rook c8 coming
probably the plan is to double up and do
something eventually start with rook c8
maybe rugby six in Bishop d4 have to
find some targets Wow
h4 let's play I'm just going to continue
with the plan in white might be able to
take now but it would be a bit messy it
takes Bishop d4 Bishop c1 okay we're
gonna find out what happens I'll start
with this move
maybe throw in g6 at some point because
g6 had prepares Bishop f5 over there's
some nice meat I'm gonna play g6 if h5
I'm forced mating with Bishop here King
here rook takes c1 rook takes c1 Bishop
b2 so sweet and if if Y doesn't play h5
I just play King g7 I trap the bishop my
rupp defends this bishop my king's not
tied down so g4 stopping stopping this I
mean I wanted like take on I mean this
would be so fun to take on c1 maybe it
can almost work take on c1 the problem
is King takes b1 Brooke take or if King
take c1 if rook takes c1 that would work
so I'm imagining like Bishop d7 it seems
hopeful but it has a very clear purpose
let's do it
I think this is a force made threat it's
important to have Bishop a4 in the end
and if for some reason it doesn't work
out why it's gonna have to spend a lot
of time figuring out how to defend a b3
seeing my threats ooh now I can't play
King g7 because rook there it's slightly
unfortunate but I can play this move of
threatening mate in one
I'm still looking nice okay Bishop where
does a bishop move I mean they'll
probably have King g7 right there's some
funny ideas too
maybe I can play Bishop h8 even oh
that's reasonable
okay oh that's actually really annoying
um let's play rook here because I want
to play Bishop d3 oh that was just a
really bad move though for multiple
reasons now I probably have to go for
the dirty flag I'm off on time oh dear
please don't destroy me oh my gosh I'm
actually getting destroyed what just
happened my beautiful position ah
there's Bishop takes d3 but you didn't
see it where's my mate where's my mate
let's just do that such a weird position
hey I won with a dirty flag oh my gosh
I'm so sorry to my opponent except it's
not really I mean but actually I'm kind
of sorry like I was such a messy finish
also I really thought there should be
made here with those discoveries
ah there's meat there's just this this
in this like rook see to the king has to
move here be to double-check and oh wait
no King see one the King can escape huh
maybe there's no means yeah I getting
into that situation I mean Bishop h8 was
just really bad but also like even even
here
I'm just King g7 and I was so enthralled
to like set up these mating I use okay I
think we have one last person in the
queue hey that was the only dirty flag
of today I believe I don't think there
is anything else that dirty last person
Seiji Morton let's find him Seiji Morton
Seiji there you are all right let's do
this
I'm gonna be aggressive let's get this
let's get this over with quickly I'm
gonna play a Maura dedicated to mark
Esserman whose book I still haven't read
but I recommend the book to anyone like
trying to learn this opening leading
theoretician the Smith Laura gambit and
I'll admit I know almost no theory but I
know that you're supposed to meet the
king eventually so let's develop pieces
first and I see six was mean reasonable
looking I guess I could castle alrighty
seems like I should have something but I
guess I'll castle first I'm waiting for
some opportunity i given knight f6 I can
play e5 if d6 maybe I can consider a v
e6 a john davis strategy what was a
lesson earlier it's very weakening to
the dark squares let's play this move
don't waste no time trying to go for the
kill a few people have done this so far
today like e-66
not a great combo this is gonna be very
similar to the john davis game because
my g5 is coming and f7 will probably
fall I could throw an e5 if I want the
f7 can't be defended
or I can wow 95 I missed not a bad move
I mean still very nice-looking position
I'm not like winning the pawn instantly
and my bishops attacked I want to play
this move allow the trade on c4 and
maybe my Bishop could enter d6
like Bishop d6 followed by 95 and still
going after f7
yeah what to do I don't want to retreat
it's one thing I mean it's one thing I
might have to do I'm looking for sax
Bishop d6 Knight takes f7 95 takes g6 uh
yeah let's have some fun last game is
meant for fun right uh take on f7
earlier I was saying you shouldn't sack
mire pieces for pawns
because minor pieces are more valuable
but these minor pieces and black most of
black's pieces just not in great shape
but it's still gonna take efforts play
e5 maybe or maybe Queen f3 first 97 also
possible there's a lot of options I'm
gonna start with rook c1 open file
potential for rock lifting bro like ever
can come to g3 it'll be nice now Paul I
completely forgot about I have like some
night check it's throw in some night
check
expecting King h8 it's so close to mate
I just need I need a queen on g8b some
weird some other mates how I made this
happen
the knight wants to take the bishop I
mean maybe I move back I could start the
process of lifting the rook I could lift
the other rook - let's lift the other
rook doing some heavy lifting all I want
is my queen to get to g8 Queen takes g8
and then Knights g6 mates if we can
finish this game or this stream even
with a smothered mates I'd be so nice I
just can't lose my Knights rook I need 7
it's completely stuck alright so now my
knight is trying to be taken if I played
Knight g6 mm-hmm I could play can i play
this move when Bishop takes e7
all right let's keep the night's night a
night f-for going for H five what's on
the mug or what's in the mug there's
green tea in the mug staying hydrated
same caffeinated sack all the pieces
I mean what's more fun sacking all the
pieces or smothered mates I still have
like dreams of some other meaning or
maybe I'll sack the night we might see
this line King g6 queen here takes the
nights and then like h3 preparing queen
g4 or even like rookie for could be nice
if the King moves back we do I do
baby queen g3 still taking effort I
don't want to trade Queens so my D like
Queen c7 then taking actually looks kind
of funny play Queen c7 this is actually
like some sort of threat it's almost
leading to mates there'd be Queen d8 in
the end I still wanted rook lifts I mean
I don't want to win this game by
flagging my opponent but it might happen
that way ooh can I be tricky I'll be
very tricky oh wait it doesn't even work
I don't think that even works I was
thinking here takes and then takes but
then there's like some Queen move
hmm I take there and now all right let's
play a for expecting the bishop to move
back how do i mate
maybe I'll just play out five I'm
clearing that Foursquare which my knight
wants to maneuver now f4 and g6 also the
pawns pinned but now okay now this is
unleashed okay now it's time to take so
I'm not sacking all the pieces if I'm
trading most of the pieces
and in the end I'll have a a very strong
protected passed pawn and black will
very likely be flagging unless pockets
made it I'm threatening made in one
defended does this work no Bishop e7 oh
let's play this move and then this move
and this move and then this move alright
let's play that move all right not the
most beautiful or aesthetic finish but a
finish nonetheless I think that's gonna
be it
I was a lot of chess I was three hours
of five minute chess I lost one game
congratulations
- I already forget the guys name whoever
beat me in the Budapest well done
if you just joined you're a little bit
too late raid botas I I don't think I
can raid anyone
oh I'm Eric Rosen raid is to boat s nice
okay so I don't even know when the raid
begins maybe it can begin now and I can
just wrap it up just mention it
oh nice okay so we're raiding botas show
some love I don't know what she's doing
but she's probably doing chess thanks
again for everyone this was really fun
probably most people know this but I
stream on Twitch - on Twitch - you can
check out my channel I am Rosen and I'll
be back in the future and I'll be a PCL
finals if anyone's gonna be in San
Francisco
alright see you guys